all right another live look at this
three o'clock hour at centennial hills
park they got a cool amphitheater there
too as you can see you wrap around the
park great park to check out for
yourself i've even seen people uh ride
their bikes and do little rc cars out
there too this is it's in 10 hills park
from our aviator drone
checking out our local parks there in
the northwest partly valley if you want
to go check that out that's on buffalo
and elkhorn all right check it out for
yourself clear skies outside right now
and notice no movement on our cameras
because those winds have been
cooperating nicely we have already
reached 80 degrees so i thought we'd
show you some flow facts our 80 degree
today was our first 80 degree officially
since november 13th it's been that long
the earliest 80 degree officially we've
ever had was february 1st back in 2003
all right currently outside 79
centennial hills somewhere at 75 degrees
we're at 78 for the lake so a little
warmer than yesterday this time we still
haven't reached our daytime high that's
going to be in the next couple of hours
81 downtown in north las vegas are in
the 80s for you from the far east side
there in sunrise manor 81 for green
valley we're at 81 also for henderson
seven hills same for you and sporada
cadence all those new neighborhoods
there silverado ranch 78 degrees and 78
also spring valley 82 right now for a
prompt 80 for boulder city we're
currently 85 down river in laughlin and
closer to 90 for death valley here's our
satellite and radar so we're just clear
all right and the reason for that is
that area of high pressure what that
does is everything gets deflected up and
over that high and that's why we're dry
here not just here all across the desert
southwest there's a high the reason for
the heat also is this
as this gets firmly anchored in the
region that allows temperatures to warm
up and that's what we're seeing today
that's why we're going to rapidly warm
up to 90s for tomorrow and also in your
weekend so here's the latest on those
record temperatures we're expecting for
friday and also saturday new numbers to
show you 90 to 91 for those days the
record like we said 87 degrees for both
days one set in 1981 one set 1947 it's
been that long we're going to break
those records and set new records the
high for 86 on sunday probably not going
to reach the record of 88 degrees but
will come close as far as the weekend
goes we're expecting increased cloud
cover but it's not until monday look at
this then we start to see some showers
encroach into the region better chances
for our weather day on monday now and
possibly around for tuesday as well
we'll keep our eye on that because that
is subject to change as we get closer to
that as well so here's the forecast
tonight temperatures will be dropping
again to the eight or i should say into
the 50s overnight 59 degrees clear and
comfortable light winds your high
tomorrow 90 extra warm tomorrow and that
will be a new record high those winds
will remain light highs tomorrow in the
high 80s to 90s i'm thinking people will
be turning on the ac tomorrow for sure
here's your eight day forecast so new
records on two days that's friday and
saturday after that we see the numbers
start to drop on sunday and then wind
kicks up sunday with chances for showers
now monday and tuesday but cooler 70s
that's your weather update faculty thank
you chad 1991 i know get excited